hi I'm Nick Kroll and I'm John Mulaney
we're here at BuzzFeed yeah we're having
trouble with this introduction because
we don't exactly know how to describe
the fact that we're gonna be targeted
teens and tweens about sex tweens is a
term I haven't heard hi Brooke hi Brooke
oh yeah this is our friend Brooke we've
just met but we're very close friends
how will these your 11:00 radio a sixth
grade Christopher are you aware that if
they make another Mullaney show that you
could play young John Mulaney how do you
feel about that I don't feel like I can
handle this go ahead
the tampon is a name that I called John
is the only behind my back yeah this is
back it to his face I call him a pad a
tampon is a it's a it's a object used by
women to soak up their menstrual blood
that they're passing through their body
which is their period there is tampons
there's also pads I use a deep it comes
how do you get someone to want to ask
you out oh I don't know I don't know
that I mean honestly Brooke this is a
question it doesn't stop in middle
school I think people like confidence
they do like confident I think but you
don't have to be comfortable with who
you are then you can fake it it's really
like you should be ideally but it is
right but I would say yeah okay also
pretend to be yes until deep in your
hair
yes okay this is a great question
they don't know they smell because it's
been like have you ever heard the
example when you put a frog a pot of
water if you slowly increase look at me
just slowly increase the water the heat
the frog won't know it's boiling
Savannah how was your day today
a man told me to boil a frog what is the
point of facial hair like are you asking
what our opinion is or do we actually
know about evolution because I don't
know anything about it I have opinions
on evolution and that it's not real yeah
I mean why do our nails grow to like I
think werewolves and no one wants to
admit
have you seen Teen Wolf that's up okay
movie but it makes an excellent point
which is when you get to high school you
turn it you know you turn into a wolf
John we can't spread to kids that they
turn they're gonna turn into wolves
what is third base anyway well it's a
90s hip-hop band for a white guy who
became Everlast that's the answer I'm
comfortable on camera giving you in a
baseball situation it's right before you
get to home base unless you get unless
the batter strikes out or you don't
steal the base John is like is
auditioning currently to play it
apparently I'm doing Field of Dreams -
yeah why do you get hair in your butt on
your butt I think I get here in my butt
because I am I did at 23andme and it
turns out that I'm 17% chia pet and so I
have hair growing out of all parts of my
body if you follow the direction I'm you
kissed with your tongue yeah oh I
thought it was when you kissed with a
cigarette breath the first time I French
kissed a girl I it was a truth or dare
and I jammed my tongue down her throat
and she did not like it and that girl
became my wife John I did not like it I
didn't like it and he could have done
without the hummus right so awkward my
boys so awkward I think boys are awkward
because probably around now like all of
a sudden I think boys realize that girls
like pretty and that they might like
them and so they don't know how to deal
with that and so they will text and then
just stop texting for some reason and
it's like why didn't you keep texting me
when do you stop like getting pimples Oh
an excellent question do you know
there's a world where you start getting
them in your late 30s I heard that if
you put toothpaste on it doesn't work it
doesn't know doesn't dry it up I heard
neosporin - no well like so what I do
before bed is I take you know the whole
regime yet do you know um do you know
what like a like a French butter is like
a nice rich French butter I'll just take
a handful of that and I'll kind of
moisturize before bed and then and then
wake up and then go straight to work
don't shower and I have found that that
has been problematic for my sleep but I
gotta say this golden retrievers have
never liked me more thank you so much
for watching thanks for doing it John
thanks for doing it Nick it was great to
hear these questions from young people
that have a lot on their minds and we I
think gave them something more to think
about the narrative the boys are just
stupid I'm now like that can't we can't
do that anymore no I don't think they're
stupid I think they're bad